[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>>> ALL RIGHT.
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT.
CANDACE AND PAUL,
HOW DO WE THINK THE SHOW IS
GOING SO FAR, AND DON'T BE
AFRAID TO BE BRUTAL.
>> WELL, I LOVED HOW THE OPENING
CREDITS WENT, OF THE SKETCH WITH
ALL THE CAST MEMBERS, KEPT GOING
AND GOING AND GOING.
IT'S VERY FUNNY.
>> WELL, NOT TO BE A TOTAL BITCH
BUT MY FIVE-TIMER SHOW IN
DECEMBER WAS GOING TO BE A LOT
BETTER.
THAT IS, UNTIL THE WHOLE CAST
DECIDED TO CALL OUT SICK.
>> WELL, THEY GOT COVID.
>> SO, WHAT?
I HAVE COVID RIGHT NOW!
I GOT IT FROM THE QUEEN.
HUMBLE BRAG.
>> HI.
I THINK I'M SUPPOSED TO BE IN
HERE.
>> AH, MEGAN MULLALLY, YEAH.
>> WELCOME TO THE FIVE-TIMERS
CLUB.
>> OH, THANK YOU, CANDICE.
CONGRATULATIONS, JOHN.
AND LET ME BE THE FIRST PERSON
TO SAY, WHO ARE YOU?
>> WELL, CANDICE, YOU WOULDN'T
KNOW ME, BUT IF YOU HAVE A NIECE
OR A SON WHO IS BAD AT SPORTS,
THEY MIGHT.
>> COME ON.
HE'S JOHN MULANEY.
CONGRATS, MAN!
>> NO.
TONIGHT IT'S ALL ABOUT YOU.
AND ME TO A DEGREE AS WELL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YOU KNOW, MY PARTY WAS
CANCELED, DUE TO LAZINESS.
>> WOW.
WELL, I'M JUST HAPPY THAT YOU'RE
IN MY EPISODE.
AND PAUL RUDD EXITS.
>> THAT'S IT?
>> SORRY, BUDDY.
I'M JUST READING.
AND TINA FEY ENTERS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> NICE ONE, JOHN.
I LOVE HOW US WRITERS CONTROL
EVERYTHING WITH STAGE
DIRECTIONS.
AND TINA IS HANDED A DRINK BY A
NEW CAST MEMBER WHOSE NAME IS, I
WANT TO SAY, PHILLIP.
>> IT'S JAMES, MISS FEY.
>> THAT'S WHAT I SAID, PHILLIP.
>> WHAT KIND OF A DRINK IS THAT?
>> MM, IT'S THE FIVE-TIMERS'
FIZZ.
IT'S MADE WITH JUSTIN TIMBERLAKE
TEQUILA, DAN AYKROYD VODKA, AND
TRACY MORGAN'S CLUB SODA, WHICH
IS AQUARIUM WATER.
>> DISGUSTING.
DAN AYKROYD VODKA?
LISTEN,
I HAVE TO SAY, I HAD NO IDEA
PEOPLE GOT TREATED THIS WELL.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I WORKED HERE, I
WAS JUST A WRITER.
>> WELL, YOU WERE ONE OF THE
BEST.
I MEAN, YOU WROTE THAT CHARACTER
WITH BILL HADER AND 800 OTHER
THINGS THAT AGED REALLY
TERRIBLY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AH, WELL, THAT'S ALL BEHIND
YOU.
TONIGHT YOU ARE IN THE COMPANY
OF COMEDY LEGENDS AND THE
SEXIEST MAN ALIVE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> OH, THIS SILLY THING?
PAUL, THAT WAS SO 2021.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT
MR. ELLIOT GOULD.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> OH, HELLO.
>> OH, MY GOD.
ELLIOT.
>> WELL, PAUL MAY HAVE "PEOPLE"
MAGAZINE, BUT I WAS NAMED
"SEXIEST MAN ALIVE" BY CHEST
HAIR MAGAZINE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HEY, ELLIOT, DO YOU REMEMBER
BEING ON MY SITCOM?
>> SHOULD I?
>> SO, JOHN, WE'VE GOT SOME
BUSINESS TO DISCUSS.
THE CLUB HERE HAS GOTTEN SO BIG
THAT IN ORDER FOR YOU TO GET IN,
SOMEONE HAS TO RETIRE.
>> YEAH, TOO BAD NO ONE HERE IS
AT RETIREMENT AGE.
>> YOU ARE 76.
>> BUT I HAVE THE CHILD OF A
38-YEAR-OLD.
AND WE GET RID OF TINA.
SHE WAS THE FIRST WOMAN TO WEAR
GLASSES ON TV.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
"ENTERTAINMENT WEEKLY" CALLED IT
DISGUSTING.
AND IT CAN'T BE CANDICE BECAUSE
SHE WAS BACK HERE IN THE '70s.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW MUCH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT HAPPENED BACK
THEN?
>> OH, PLEASE.
THOSE GUYS DID REALLY WEIRD
STUFF.
>> I WAS FINE WITH IT.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S NO
ROOM FOR ME?
>> THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
VERY SMALL CLUB, WITH JUST THE
HIGHEST QUALITY STARS.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS --
>> I THINK WHAT WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO SAY IS THIS HAS BECOME NOT
SPECIAL.
>> DID SOMEONE SAY --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> DID SOMEBODY SAY NOT SPECIAL?
>> CONAN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
HERE?
>> WELL, I'M JUST HERE TO SIGN
UP FOR PEACOCK.
IT'S WEIRD THEY MAKE YOU DO IT
IN PERSON.
>> OH.
>> LOOK, JOHN, DO NOT LISTEN TO
THEM.
THIS IS VERY SPECIAL.
I WAS IN THE VERY FIRST
FIVE-TIMERS SPECIAL -- THING
WHEN I WAS A WRITER HERE.
>> A LOT OF US WERE WRITERS
HERE.
>> YES.
BUT YOU WERE ON THE SHOW WHEN
YOU WERE A WRITER, SO SHUT UP!
JOHN AND I WERE NEVER SUPPOSED
TO BE ON TV.
'CAUSE WE'RE BOTH HIDEOUS,
RIGHT?
RIGHT, JOHN!
>> I -- I GUESS.
>> YES, WE ARE!
WE'RE HERE AND WE'RE TAKING
WHAT'S OURS.
WE WANT TO TAKE IT BY THE HORNS.
THE POINT IS, YOU START HERE AND
YOU CAN DO GREAT THINGS.
I HOSTED MY OWN TV SHOW FOR
DECADES.
AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING NOW?
>> I HAVE A PODCAST.
>> WELL, I NEVER THOUGHT I'D SAY
THIS, BUT CONAN HAS A POINT.
BEING IN THIS CLUB IS PRETTY
DAMN SPECIAL.
>> YES!
YES!
COME ON.
LET'S GIVE HIM HIS JACKET.
>> ALL RIGHT, PAUL.
GIVE HIM YOUR JACKET.
>> AH, MAN.
IT WAS FUN WHILE IT LASTED.
>> GUYS, EVERYONE.
THANK YOU.
THIS -- THIS REALLY DOES --
JUST, IT MEANS THE WORLD TO ME.
>> OH YEAH.
AND HEY, ONE MORE THING.
LIVE FROM NEW YORK --
>> OH, NO, CONAN.
WE DID THAT ALREADY.
>> I'LL DOING IT ANYWAY.
LIVE FROM NEW YORK, IT'S
SATURDAY NIGHT!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]